en la recta numérica cuál es el número
que más se aproxima a la representación
de la raíz principal de 43 o la raíz
cuadrada de 43 entonces puedes poner
pausa al vídeo y solo observando esto
intenta aproximarse a la ubicación de
ahí bebé luego piensa en cuál de estos
dos números es el más cercano a la raíz
cuadrada de 43 así que analicemos a cada
uno el punto aparece que está un poco
más alejado de la mitad cierto entre 6.5
y 6.6 la mitad entre 6.5 y 6.6 es
aproximadamente esto lo cual yo calculo
que es como 6.55 así que creo que es
aproximadamente 6.56 parece ser que es
aproximadamente 6.56 elevemos esto al
cuadrado y veamos que obtenemos entonces
6.56 x 6.56 obviamente la calculadora
podría suponer 6.56 supreme es un botón
que eleva al cuadrado y ya obtienen la
respuesta pero aquí no lo no voy a usar
la calculadora
espero no equivocarme entonces vamos a
multiplicar estos 6 por 6 36 6 por 5 33
33 6 por 6 36 3 39 ahora vamos con este
5 este 5 voy a poner un 0 aquí 5 por 6
30 y luego 5 por 5 25 3 28 y 5 por 6 32
que llevamos igual a 32
ahora ya multiplicamos 6 por 6 56 cierto
entonces simplemente pongo aquí dos
ceros y pongo 6 3 9 y 3
ahora vamos a sumar esto cuando sumamos
esto que obtenemos obtenemos 6 3
89 es igual a 17 6 es igual a 23 luego 2
más 13 55 igual a 10 después tenemos 49
es igual a 13 y 4 ahora 12 34 números
detrás de los decimales entonces 1-2-3-4
ahí va el punto decimal obtenemos 43.03
36 eso es bastante cercano a la raíz
cuadrada de 43 cierto vaya que sí está
muy muy cerca entonces yo creo que a va
a ser la respuesta pero vamos a
intentarlo con b vamos a elevar a b al
cuadrado aunque observando bien esto no
es necesario porque como puedes observar
a se aproxima bastante y de hecho es
mayor que 43 así que al cuadrado si nos
aproximamos bien a esto tenemos que 6.56
elevado al cuadrado lo cual es igual a
43 puntos 0 336 ya
es mayor que 43 cierto esto es mayor que
43 otra manera de pensar en esto es que
6.56 es mayor que la raíz cuadrada de 43
así que a parece ser que se acercó
bastante y de hecho se pasó es un poco
más grande que 43 entonces ahora como ve
es mayor que a b al cuadrado nos
alejaría más de 43 por lo tanto b no
puede ser la respuesta que queremos así
que nos vamos con a y de hecho que ven
use la respuesta correcta nos ahorra
bastantes cuentas cierto así que es la
respuesta que más se aproxima a raíz
cuadrada de 43